speaking earlier about the guys in
California being not as masculine as you
like like what's the typical dude that
you come across in California like um
it's what I mean I would
say they're more you know and they're
like more
feminine um they for sure you know want
everything to be
equal which you know I guess
wom most I would say but not you um you
know and as when it comes to equal I
would
say yes and
no
not like what I would like to have that
that option but I would I would like the
the man to not you know to
basically want to to be 100% the
masculine man in my life you know um but
if I had that option you know that would
be great as well that that might be too
much to ask for you know there there's
but there's not a lot of defined Clarity
coming out of that though like when I'm
asking you the question as far as as far
as what a typical Dude Looks like that
you've been meeting in California that's
not very masculine um I'm not getting a
lot of definition coming from from you
as far as what you you know what you
expect what you look for what the guy's
behaving like so let me ask you the
question this
way if I can produce a magic wand and
wave it right now to solve your problems
when it comes to a dude and dating what
would that look like if I wave that
right now I guess someone that has the
same values as me you know is honest it
like
communicates I would like somebody that
can is great with their hands does like
a lot of you know maybe like build some
stuff I don't
I I'm I'm very easygoing so it's really
hard to explain what I want when I
there's I everything that I want I could
do for myself Rachel while bry's doing
that um are you running the same sort of
problem that Brandy sort of describes
with guys that you meet in Florida like
are they more
feminine um no honestly honestly no not
particularly I don't find myself around
I I mean they're there I see them yeah
but I feel like um whenever I was living
in Virginia which was a very like um a
blue very blue area politically they
were absolutely everywhere but um since
I moved back to Florida I don't really
have that issue too much no is there is
there any woman that you gals know that
like softer feminine sort of
guys like within your friends sisters
like anybody that you know uh my um my
sister
probably yeah yeah my sister yeah i'
never um she's she's been with um her
the same man since she was 15 so good
for her but um they he's definitely more
more feminine and my whole family like
it's something that we would recognize
but it's not it's not necessarily A Bad
Thing their Dynamic works but it's just
not something I'm attracted to
particularly so who leads that
relationship she does or he
does oh um I would say like if they got
to get in the car and drive somewhere
who drives the car well actually he he
drives absolutely everywhere um but the
thing is is that as far as like leading
the relationship how it seems just seems
like it's like that word like like a
partnership I just don't really feel
like there's anyone really driving it
per se okay um like okay so whenever she
moved to um Washington DC so very blue
place whenever she moved there he uh
would he just kind of dropped everything
and followed her like he just kind of
just moved to wherever she was um going
because of her career so it was it was
more driven towards that like he's
geared a lot of his things as far as
what he's doing toward work to be um
closer to her and to be with her okay
all right M have we ever had a gal on
that is overtly stated that they like
softer more feminine men
no never one right I thought I can think
of I would I would love to talk to one
of these gals that like softer feminine
sort of like male male feminist sort of
dudes I don't know ladies if you're
watching this if you're watching a
replay MFS Instagram handle is in the
bottom we want to have you on one of
these shows and have a bit of a
conversation it's uh moff unplugged on
Instagram definitely reach out dude MF
it is it is so beyond me how we've done
all these episodes now we haven't had a
single galon that's like I want a softer
more agreeable more feminine man that's
in my frame that will follow me wherever
I go and be my sorry we have actually
had women say that I want a cheerleader
right like I want somebody to Raw raw me
on but this but in the next breath it's
I want a strong masculine guy I want a
guy to lead you know I want a guy to you
know take care of things um all right so
Rachel for your for your situation so
you're moving to Fort Lauderdale uh MRI
tech um how long have you been in
Florida for you said that you grew up in
Virginia or you sp I was living I was
living in Virginia for a little bit um
for like two years yeah but um after
covid I just decided to come back
because Florida was just a better place
to live during that time but I'm from
Florida like I've born and raised here
so I was just returning back all right
yeah yeah yeah the restrictions were
kind of brutal during that time yeah um
what do you seeing in I mean I
understand that you're moving to another
part of the state but when you're out
are you running into the same sort of
problems where you're coming across too
many feminine guys or like what sort of
struggles are you running into when it
comes to your life
um I I think for for the kind of guys
that I'm meeting it's really hard to
answer because I'm outside of work I'm
not meeting any any guys and what I do
for a living is I work as a server and
so the the kind of guys that I work with
are not not the kind of guy I would want
to be with at all so yeah so those are
the only men that I really surround
myself and I don't really know I don't
really know where else to put myself in
situations to where I could find that
more but um I so for me to say I've met
more feminine guys or not I don't I
don't think I have but I have you said
that that when you work as a server
you're running into the kind of guys
that you wouldn't date is it the guys
you work with or the
customers oh um or both no not the
customers uh St Pete's a really nice
area there's a lot of like great people
success people that live here too um but
um I'm talking about like the people
that like I work with MH they usually
are like um very much into like little
addictions they aren't very good with
their money they like they're not really
looking forward to elevate them in
themselves in any way like my job that
I'm doing just for the meantime is like
the most that they are trying to get at
like they're very they're very content
with being where we're at MH and and
that's just not the kind of person that
I want to be with so I'm just I don't
even think about them in that way at all
so how ambitious does a guy have to be
for
you um ambitious enough to have like
that itch where you always want to keep
better H get better and make more and be
better for yourself I just don't feel
like they they have that in them at
all and it's there's a lot of guys that
are that are that are pretty rudderless
in life today where they just don't have
a plan a vision a goal right purpose
right and um like whenever I mean it
just seems to be for for me and my
experiences whenever I meet a man that
doesn't know his purpose or he's
insuring that or he's just settling
that's just they're really hard to to be
with because it's just
they I just feel like men are Hunters if
they're not hunting after like the
things having their own purpose they
start to go to other things that aren't
fulfilling or aren't good
so
vices right yeah exactly vices is the
word what sort of vices do these guys
pick up
normally um it's usually things like
addictions like like gambling addictions
a lot of them are like addicted to Vapes
which I think is super gross like
they're in their like 30s and 40s vaping
they buy like Aderall off each other um
they go spend their money after work at
the bars you see a lot of that in the
service industry um they have a lot of
like anger issues they're very like mad
at life in a way but they act like
they're not what are they mad at like
what sort of anger issues are we talking
about um they they like explode over
things at work like things like just it
can get busy and people get frazzled
sometimes in service and they just they
take it way too
seriously and it's they you can see them
get really angry not have control over
their
emotion what sort of age range do you
normally date with when you know you're
out there putting yourself out there um
honestly it it ranges
from 20 I think the youngest would be 25
for me because I'm
24 um but the oldest I would say it
would probably be
33 why do it why is 33 the Line in the
Sand
um I'm not I'm not exactly sure I think
the only thing that comes to my mind is
my like family I don't know if they I
really don't know if how they would feel
about that because the oldest person
that I had dated was 32 yeah and they
were comfortable with that I don't know
if they would be comfortable with me
dating someone higher it's not that I'm
not really I'm just considering other
factors do you find when you date guys
that are older that they're able to
regulate themselves better they don't
have outbursts you know anger issues
they don't have
devices pretty much the same you know
consistently through it all I would say
I would say yeah but um yeah I know uh
because the guys that I work with
they're around that age range they're
like 30 to 40 and they they don't
regulate themselves that great I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out